yeah podcast this guy still doesn't want
to do an interview but he said he'll rap
man we going to come back and do one
about that bag do an interview bro we
he's independent he's currently being uh
everyone in their mom's coming at him
trying to sign him he's like LeBron
James in 2011 yeah no for real 2010
whatever year that was I don't know what
year was everybody's just offering I was
like 10 years old I yeah don't age me
bro anyway look man let's get right to
it sack sack Town's finest in the
[__] building let's light the
beam on they ass you know what I'm
saying
hey think they saying real [__] fake ass
[__] think they saying real
[__] hey all these fake ass [__] think
they saying real [__] I just want to
talk [__] don't make me send a hit stick
I see you got the same car same [__]
same drip all on Instagram always
whooping about the same [__] I'm that
[__] I ain't never had to ride a [__]
wave I was that little [__] running
around the South within braids I'm that
[__] no hesitation dub on a chain I'm
that [__] no registration forign
switching lanes I'm that [__] Talking
Money [__] and put us on the map I'm
that [__] took the mails and [__] I
really made it back I'm that [__] told
the Kings to drop a bag for me to rap
real step was going for me let me rap or
get rap have a ticket off a rap that's
all streams no cap that dog [__] I show
on Instagram and show Money [__] so
phony but they want to verse it's so
funny the [__] told me I could take it
out her purse that's your money took
another trip to Utah and knocked the
snow bunny I could tell when [__]
playing with that pack your nose R I can
see these [__] playing with my top
don't know nothing I be trying to play
cool but I be want to smoke something
cousin catch this [__] at the spot and
get this sto jumping big bag on me that
it's looking like I stole something if
the [__] per say don't touch I'm going
to touch it think I see why [__] mad
at me cuz they [__]
[__] for switching Lane hey hey no
hesitation dub on the Chain [__] drop a
yeah I'm that [__] told the Kings to
drop a bag for me to rap No Cap shout
out to the owner of the Kings his
daughter's very very nice I djed for her
once she be sing she the one that tapped
in with me yeah she used to be a singer
I DJ she yeah she used to do R&B she D
for real she had she put I [__] djed
for her in Florida once 2014 she had
like music out D that's crazy I didn't
know that she tapped you would never be
able to tell like by looking at her
Instagram and [__] Sacramento power
couple you and her huh let's make it
happen anyway whoa TB about that
bag hey you just watched another
freestyle brought to you by the good
Folks at LRG godamn it shout out to LRG
all right go use the promo code bootleg
right now on their website l-r-g.com say
40% off at checkout 40% off at check out
use that promo code and we got another
freestyle coming ASAP